but this is what the demolition looks
like in fact junior traffic buddy hector
mayhe is right there at di which is
closed in both directions as crews are
basically going to be replacing the
bridge there right hector
that is true good morning to you nate
you just mentioned the brake light
parade now let's show you the roadblock
in orange cone parade this is happening
right now here at di underneath the
us-95 bridge now during the distance you
can see chunks of the high wind actually
right now as i speak some chunks are
falling from the freeway right now and
crashing onto the d.i you can see some
smoke on the ground there some light
smoke as some of those pieces are
falling down we're told by ndot that
they are partially
demolishing u.s 95 as part of the
ongoing 40 million dollar rehabilitation
project on the freeway desert enclosed
at midnight yesterday in both directions
under the 95 bridge the off ramp to
boulder highway from northbound 95 has
also been shut down during the overnight
hours we are told the demolition process
will last at least until saturday and
here's an interesting fact if you're
wondering why crews are not moving
around or doing anything right this
minute that's because the demolition
work itself is being restricted to the
hours of 7 a.m to 7 p.m to limit noise
and dust disruptions to the
neighborhoods in the area but we've been
seeing crews on the ground throughout
the morning actually since we started
since we got here the road is closed and
so is the sidewalk but we've seen cars
coming up to the roadblocks making
u-turn also people actually walking
underneath the bridge even though
they're working on this demolition
process anyway the road work itself the
closure is expected to last until until
at least saturday as crews work on the
project and we have machines moving
moving right now as all this ongoing
road work is happening an active
construction zone right now so we're
going to send it back over to you guys
for now reporting live hector mejia 8
news now back to you guys